what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have a new
look at some of the characters that are
going to be in black panther 2 wakanda
forever we have official art for black
panther wakanda forever that has been
released and we get our very first look
at ironheart what her armor is going to
be looking like we also get a new look
at nakia and it definitely looks like
she is going to have a bigger role to
play in black panther wakanda forever
also it seems like we've learned a
little bit more about just who the new
black panther is going to be and as i've
stated in some previous videos it looks
like there could actually be more than
one black panther wakanda forever has
the potential to set up many different
things of course i think most of us have
heard the rumor that dr doom could
actually be the one that is behind the
wakanda atlantis war if you haven't
heard that it's definitely a big
possibility and could even be a major
plot point for black panther 2 and even
a future black panther film if you are
not aware of what the doom war storyline
is we're going to talk about that in
this video but basically what you need
to know is that doom has successfully
taken over wakanda and there are two
black panthers t'challa and shuri and it
looks like we could be getting a little
bit of that in the mcu hopefully pretty
soon and also storm is a part of that
storyline as well and of course with the
mutants now being in the mcu this could
be an opportunity to actually introduce
storm into the mcu more on this in a bit
but let's first go over our new look at
riri williams as ironheart technically
this could be the first time we are
actually seeing her suit really we've
only seen it before i believe with just
lego leaks there could have been another
leak out there but this is official art
from the movie so this is our first real
official look and as you can see here it
actually looks pretty cool now keep in
mind that this is going to be designed
by riri williams herself so she doesn't
have access at least not at first to all
of the equipment and materials that tony
stark had when making his iron man suit
except for his first suit in which riri
williams's iron heart suit is kind of
going to resemble the mark 1 iron man
the one that he made in a cave and why
is that well that was iron man's first
suit that he made and this is riri
williams's first suit that she makes now
this is actually quite different than
the iron heart armor model 1 that she
makes in the comics for the very first
time but of course it is the mcu and
this is actually a little bit more
realistic the one that we're seeing here
in the movie however keep in mind and
we've seen this in the trailer she is
going to get materials from wakanda
we've seen her in wakanda we've seen her
in shuri's lab and we've seen her
actually making the iron heart armor so
i think it's safe to say that this is
just her first suit and is definitely
not going to be the final suit that we
see her in in black panther wakanda
forever now there have been some leaked
photos of the iron heart suit that is
going to be in the iron heart series and
possibly and probably in black panther
wakanda forever i can't show them due to
copyright reasons i'll get this video
taken down but essentially they confirm
that this suit that she has is going to
change over time but of course we knew
that riri williams is a genius and she
bases her iron heart armors off of iron
man armors and iron man armors have
always evolved and grown and changed and
it's no different for riri she's always
going to be thinking of new ideas for
her iron heart armor so it'll
consistently change now we do have some
art for other characters as well most of
these we have already seen in the
trailer but here are some great looks at
some of the characters coming in black
panther to wakanda forever one of them
being namora who in the comics is
actually the cousin of namor we then
have a picture of atuma who you might
have seen before atuma is actually a
villain in marvel comics who tries to
take over the throne right now we're
unsure on whether or not atuma is indeed
going to want the throne of atlantis or
if he's simply going to be a good guy in
the mcu we'll have to wait and see on
that but what's really cool is we have a
new look at nakia who's wearing an
outfit that we've never seen her wear
before we also see her holding some new
ring weapons which are probably going to
be pretty cool after all it is wakandan
technology and the suit actually looks
like it is probably made from the same
material and technology that the black
panther suits are made out of so
vibranium and of course wakandan
technology however saying that i do want
to clarify that i do not believe that
she is going to be a new black panther i
do believe it's going to be shuri and we
do have a look at shuri here but it's
actually a look that we've seen before
of her and her purple outfit now going
back to do more doom wants vibranium
that is something that is probably going
to be true in the mcu however in the
comics doom is successful at taking over
wakanda and in the comics it literally
takes the help of the x-men the
fantastic four and even deadpool to
fight doctor doom and there are two
black panthers like i mentioned t'challa
and his sister shuri and to add to it
storm's life is in jeopardy and they
only have a couple of days to save her
now something that of course we know is
that marvel studios doesn't ever simply
adapt something from the comics page by
page what they really do is take
inspiration from the comics and twist
the stories and make it their own they
make it fresh so we don't know what's
actually going to happen because if they
did page by page we would and i believe
that in black panther wakanda forever we
are about to see the start of the do war
storyline and i say the start because i
think it's pretty slim that doctor doom
is going to be introduced as a prominent
character in black panther wakanda
forever if anything he's probably going
to be set up in a post-credits scene if
that's what marvel is planning but i'll
also make it clear that i do believe
doom is on his way to the mcu soon some
rumors even say that he's coming before
the end of the year and of course black
panther wakanda forever comes out in
november before the end of the year so
fingers crossed on this one but what
would doom be doing in black panther
wakanda forever well he'd be after
vibranium not only is it probably the
most expensive thing in the world
obviously its physical properties are
very useful to somebody like doctor doom
not only for business but also for
villainry keep in mind doctor doom is an
incredibly powerful sorcerer in the
comics in fact in the comics he even at
one point wants to be the sorcerer
supreme we know that he is eventually
going to be a villain in the mcu and
vibranium would only make him even more
powerful now right now we don't know the
exact story of black panther wakanda
forever but we do know that neymar and
atlantis or whatever they're going to
call his city in the mcu is going to
fight against wakanda this of course is
going to be provoked somehow namor is
going to be provoked and doctor doom
could be behind that so as i said this
could be the start of the do more
storyline now as far as who the new
black panther is i believe that it's
going to be shuri in the film however i
do think the ending is going to leave it
open for a new black panther to actually
come in maybe alongside shuri maybe even
replacing her and if we are heading into
a very similar story to black panther do
more there should be two black panthers
shuri being one of them and then a male
black panther and honestly i think that
this could be a pretty good idea but i
don't think it's going to happen until
the next black panther movie i think
that the black panther that we see at
the end where we just see kind of the
leg and the claws come out i think
that's shuri i don't know if she's going
to go on to become queen of black
panther or if somebody like umbaku is
going to be king but i do believe that
at the end it is going to be shuri
against namor and i kind of hope it's
not like a batman vs superman thing or
like a godzilla versus kong thing where
the two of them fight but then of course
they have to come together to fight a
greater evil i hope that it ends with
one of them actually being defeated it's
probably going to be neymar but we know
that he's probably going to be around
for a pretty long time but if the war
keeps going then we could get into the
doom war storyline once doom actually
gets into the mcu and he could use
vibranium to become one of the most
powerful persons not only on the planet
but in the universe if they actually
combine his resources with the vibranium
with his sorceress skills and i actually
think that this is what we're in for i
think this is going to lead up to secret
wars where hopefully we will get a god
emperor doom and black panther wakanda
forever could set that up now i also do
think we could see storm i believe that
she could be at the funeral of t'challa
in wakanda forever storm and t'challa
were married in the comics they could
say that they had a relationship in the
mcu before t'challa was with akia heck
maybe they could even say that they were
indeed married before but got a divorce
or they could simply say that they were
friends any type of relationship though
would call for her arriving at
t'challa's funeral so you never know
since the x-men are now in the mcu
specifically kamala khan we could get a
storm cameo in black panther wakanda
forever but let me know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below what do you think about this look
at iron heart and do you think that this
is the start of doom war in the mcu let
me know your thoughts down below please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the mcu for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof